I'm joined today by Ryan Cooper who's a
national correspondent at the week has a
very interesting piece out about the
Roseanne Barr Fiasco which we've sort of
been pulled into a little bit she very
very angrily called me a bully on
Twitter Ryan just to give you a little
bit of context after I sort of jokingly
poked fun at the idea that ambien might
have made her racist or at least
disinhibited her enough that she would
be willing to tweet racist things but in
in your piece you talk about Roseanne in
a sense as a sort of martyr of a sort
making herself a martyr and some
followers of hers doing the same thing
can you talk about that a little bit
what did you mean by that well I mean
basically the first thing to remember
about Roseanne is that she literally has
like a severe mental illness apparently
multiple personality disorder and has a
sort of characteristic a lot of paranoid
political views that tend to swing back
and forth very quickly from one extreme
to the other you know in 2012 she was a
green party she was trying to get the
Green Party nomination for president
right in 2009 she was calling Israel a
Nazi state and now she's a fanatical
Zionist and a fanatical trump supporter
and one of the characteristics of the of
the just you know normal Trump
supporters is just a kind of more
moderate version of what Roseanne's
apparent inability to stop posting and
stop posting classic Trumpy stuff which
is racism against immigrants against
Muslims and Arabs and black people as
well so you know this is just like you
know what ABC wanted was to sort of cash
in on on some Trump pop political stuff
to just say like we're gonna have a
trump II show by a trump supporter where
the
character is also a Trump supporter and
they got what they were asking for and
they show God great ratings at least at
first but then you know it turns out
that that comes with the actual Trump
beliefs one of which is violence racism
anybody having to do with the Obama
administration especially and so you
know he caught calling Valerie Jarrett
uh you know of um a p-- is just what
you're going to get with that yeah man I
think that anybody who was sort of like
surprised by the comment was just not
paying attention to Rosanna for the last
many many years and I want to get back
to the mental illness component it's in
a second to talk about this from ABC's
perspective my analysis from day one was
that neither the reboot of the series
nor the firing of Roseanne has any
connection to any sort of moral or
ethical value judgment of the show nor
of anything that Roseanne did it's been
just business decisions all along the
reboot as you mentioned was out of this
idea that it could be great business to
do a show that seems to sort of be
sympathetic to the down-home Trump
supporting good old whatever of Middle
America and the firing also was what
they assessed to be the best business
decision at the time but to ascribe any
morality to it I I think is wrong unless
you think otherwise no I don't I mean
certainly you can't perceive any of that
maybe there was some sort of buried
moral trigger in the black hearts of ABC
executives that was finally dredged up
by this last tweet but you know they
there was the audio of them ABC
executives in an advertising meeting
they were they were joking about how
Trump's or sorry
Roseanne's tweets were so incredibly
offensive and weird so yeah I think it
was it was a purely business decision
there was just a calculation of you know
ratings versus diluting the brand equity
or sparking a potential boycott for
liberals you know it's like at a certain
point you didn't want to cut your losses
but yeah there was no morality here the
Mental Illness thing I mean the you
pointed out some of the the ideas that
Roseanne has has parroted retweeted over
the last many years it includes you know
CIA mind control conspiracy theory stuff
about George Soros involved in almost
every area of life that at some point
somebody has suggested and I think that
that's something that is either often
missed or sort of miscalculated when we
think about some of these incidents that
happen publicly I mean the the pattern
is this sort of paranoid delusions that
seem to have been an underlying theme of
a lot of the political conspiracies that
she subscribed to how should we as the
public account for the fact that whether
it's Roseanne or somebody else there do
sometimes seem to be significant mental
illness components to these implosion x'
that take place publicly I mean how
should the general public account for
that in our reaction you know that's a
really hard question it's you know I
mean the the the question of assigning
morale you know liability to someone who
may not be in full possession of you
know their faculties I feel like it's
it's kind of a case-by-case basis you
know because you know there are lots and
lots of different kinds of mental
illness people are you know some of them
are mild and don't interfere with
people's ability to reason while others
you know this can be totally
debilitating where people are are not
even you know coherent at all
this seems like kind of somewhere in the
middle you know I I it certainly to me
seems like there is an and kind of an
uncomfortable element of exploitation in
this and that Roseanne you know
she she does by all accounts have
serious mental illness that may not be
being treated properly and her wild
antics get tons of attention and ABC you
know clearly knew about that and was
capitalizing on it and you know what she
may have needed was not this kind of
immense at level of celebrity and
attention and more like you know of some
therapy and and Gianna treatment of some
sort but on the other hand you know I
mean it doesn't I mean obviously I don't
know Rosanna personally I've never met
her or anything like that but she
doesn't seem like someone who is
completely senseless you know she can
still speak and she certainly seems to
have you know honestly held awful views
about you know black people and Arabs
and Muslims and and you know George
Soros so I don't know you know
ultimately I guess it would I would come
down and somewhere in the middle
thinking that you know Rosanna is not
without blame but it's it's a bit of an
exculpatory factor being unwell in that
way you've in addition to writing about
Roseanne and we're gonna link to your
article about that you've also talked
about the intellectual dark web
so-called intellectual dark web a bit
and this sort of free speech warrior
movement that is out there and I think
that that's interesting in this story
because there is a group of people that
like to or at least first analyze
stories through the lens of the
so-called battle of ideas which I have a
hard time even saying non-city really at
this point or through the lens of free
speech and censorship and I found it
interesting that some of the individuals
who last week applauded the decision of
the National Football League to say you
now are not allowed to sit or
Neal or or not stand basically during
the national anthem if you're gonna be
on the field before a football game and
applauded that decision are saying that
the decision now made by ABC to fire
Roseanne is somehow an impingement on
her free speech or censorship of
comments that she made outside of her
employment relationship with ABC or
whatever fundamentally aren't these just
both cases of private businesses making
decisions that they calculate are the
right business decisions for them and
that I guess let me couch the question
this way is there any way you can even
conceive of in which one might have a
different opinion of the NFL decision
and the ABC opinion are there any
material differences I would say it's a
very it's very similar in one sense in
that yes you know these are these are
private businesses I think that you
could make a you could make a tolerable
sort of constitutional argument that you
know this that the case of the NFL
players you know not then they're not
saying anything in you know any sort of
explicit way but just you know sort of
is this like passive demonstration is it
is constitutionally protected speech in
a way that just like egregiously
offending the you know your bosses it's
not but you know I mean it I think it
goes to the heart though of the totally
unserious way that this so-called
intellectual dark web issue has been
treated you know you you have a bunch of
people who you know this Jordan Pederson
and and Dave Rubin and so forth who are
being set up you know as these like
victims of
of oppression but there's no real kind
of attempt to articulate the differences
you know and and systematically
investigate the issue of suppressed
speech which is absolutely rampant in
this country and usually it you know the
worst cases all usually involves stuff
like Palestinian BDS activists and so
forth
they've literally lots of attempts to
make that kind of speech illegal and not
just like people yell at you on Twitter
but yeah you know it it certainly you
know that this
I think the Roseann case was
particularly illustrative because this
would be a case where you could buy the
lights of the kind of intellectual dark
web people you know they ought to have
raised the exact same stink over that as
they have over you know other instances
of people being mean people losing their
jobs but in this case the comment was so
racist that there you know there was
just if it was you know indefensible and
I think it goes to the heart of what
these that this the Barry Weiss and so
forth are actually doing which is
constructing tendentious definitional
sort of fortresses around their
preferred positions and not any sort of
rigorous defense of free speech as such
yeah it seems that the free speech
component is one that is a tool to use
when useful given the circumstances and
not actually sort of a true
philosophical principle sort of to
explore and the depth that it probably
should be
Ryan Cooper is a national correspondent
at the week we are going to link to some
of his recent articles Ryan great to
speak to you today thanks for having me